dernier règle de la politique monétaire
des banques centrales c'est la banque
centrale qui soutient à bout de bras
tout l'édifice si jamais elle arrête à
ce moment-là tout c'est comment on va
pouvoir se défaire de ça c'est la
question la plus belle une problématique
et on voit bien que on arrive à un
moment où on lâche tout
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles pas les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement ils sont coupés de tout
il n'est pas dans un hôtel capturé avec
un téléphone et il peut nous donner des
nouvelles non à votre avis quelles sont
ses conditions de détention aujourd'hui
c'est sûr elles sont très difficiles
parce que les anciens otages ont pu nous
le raconter qu'il a des conditions de
vie qui sont très rudimentaires et très
dur j'espère vraiment de tout mon coeur
qui qui ressemble notre énergie moi
j'essaye de faire de mon mieux bien sûr
tout simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent
parce que c'est ça mon travail c'est la
france n valley où la france ou le mali
qui vont libérer olivier g pas ce
pouvoir de libérer mais par contre j'ai
le devoir de mobilisation je ne
l'abandonnerai part je ne laisserai pas
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
qui de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 18 janvier jean
michel blanquer relie regretté la
symbolique de ces vacances à ibiza
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
cible de toutes les critiques après la
révélation par mediapart de son séjour
sur cette île réputée festive des
baléares et ce à la veille de l'annoncé
du protocole sanitaire dans les écoles
est en pleine explosion surtout des
contaminations aux variants omicron un
acte impardonnable pour certains
opposants qui demandent purement et
simplement sa démission du gouvernement
alors jean michel blanquer le fusible
idéal on ouvre le débat dans quelques
minutes et on attend évidemment vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france
au royaume-uni opération sauvetage pour
le premier ministre qui est lui aussi en
premier en mauvaise posture en cause son
comportement déplacé pendant la pandémie
après des révélations en cascade sur des
fêtes dans sa résidence officielle en
plein confinement morisien sun temps de
se défendre dernier scandale en date
mais 2020 le dirigeant britannique est
accusé d'avoir participé à une fête
contraire aux règles antico vide dans
l'essonne signe et persiste en affirmant
une nouvelle fois qu'ils pensaient
participer à une réunion travail
et bien la une de cette émission
également la crise ukrainienne toujours
dans l'impasse les états unis estiment
ce soir que la russie peut attaquer
l'ukraine à tout moment et prévient
qu'aucune option n'était exclue pour y
répondre la russie elle réclame toujours
des réponses concrètes à ces exigences
notamment le nom énergie cement de
l'otan le chef de la diplomatie
américaine rencontrera son homologue
russe vendredi à genève après s'être
entretenu aujourd'hui par téléphone avec
lui alors que peut-on attendre de cette
rencontre vendredi on tâchera d'y voir
plus clair avec et xavier moreau notre
expert
au sommaire à 21h la flambée des prix à
la pompe le carburant atteint de
nouveaux records en france en une
semaine le prix moyen du gaz oil a
grimpé de 3 centimes plus 2 centimes
pour le sans plomb une hausse qui suit
celle du cours du pétrole alors quelles
réponses politiques à cette mauvaise
nouvelle pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français emmanuel macron et il
impuissant face à ces augmentations
records vous pouvez a toujours rcj lire
sur notre compte et d g pour alimenter
notre départ
[Musique]
est décidément l'année commence mal pour
jean michel blanquer a déjà critiqué
pour sa gestion de l'épidémie à l'école
il fait face à une nouvelle polémique en
cause des vacances à ibiza juste avant
la rentrée de janvier ces révélations
risquent de mettre de l'huile sur le feu
à l'avant veille d'une nouvelle journée
de grève des enseignants on en parle
tout de suite avec estelle fav en direct
ministère de l'éducation nationale
bonsoir estelle cette nouvelle polémique
fait vivement réagir une partie de
l'opposition qui réclame carrément le
départ du ministre un
oui oui stéphanie à droite comme à
gauche les vacances du ministre à ibiza
ont du mal à passer trop c'est trop jean
michel blanquer doit démissionner a par
exemple tweets et mathilde de panneaux
la cheffe du groupe la france a soumise
à l'assemblée nationale chez les
écologistes on évoque un niveau de
mépris et d'irresponsabilité qui n'est
pas acceptable à droite certains assomme
le ministre de s'expliquer sur ce fiasco
pour reprendre les propos du porte
parole l ère de la candidate à la
présidentielle valérie pécresse de son
côté jean michel blanquer a reconnu que
son choix de destination n'était
peut-être pas si judicieux écoutez
c'était cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale
il y as je le reconnais une symbolique
il se trouve que le lieu que j'ai choisi
j'aurais dû en choisir sans doute un
autre la symbolique je la regrette mais
pour le reste
madame la députée depuis deux ans avec
la majorité avec mes équipes avec tous
les professeurs de france nous tenons la
politique de l'école ouverte c'est cela
qui est l'essentiel et nous nous perdons
pas dans l'accessoire
et face au tollé gabriela talent le
porte parole du gouvernement a assuré
que le ministre de l'éducation nationale
avait respecté les règles s'agissant
être des vacances du gouvernement c'est
à dire être joignables en permanence et
être à sa tâche aucune raison de penser
que ce n'était pas le cas a indiqué le
porte parole du gouvernement merci
estelle phare notre reporter en direct
depuis le ministère de l'éducation
nationale et malgré le mea culpa du
principal intéressé à l'assemblée
nationale cet après midi à trois mois
donc de la présidentielle cette affaire
que l'on qualifie déjà d'ibiza gueye
dans la presse et sur les réseaux
sociaux en flammes la classe politique
une partie de l'opposition qui à la
faute politique et demandent la
démission du ministre de l'éducation
nationale d'où le ton notre débat ce
soir jean michel blanquer réty le
fusible idéal emmanuel macron qui
s'apprête à lancer sa campagne doit-il
sont débarrassés comme le demandent
certains membres de l'opposition c'est
l'objet de notre débat et face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir franck
louvrier mer et l'air de la baule
conseiller politique de valérie pécresse
candidate à la présidentielle 2022
bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau pierre cabaret
député la république en marge de la
haute-garonne merci à vous plaire
cabaret d'être avec nous et bonsoir et
par skype et gaytan dussault ses
conseillers rn1 en ile-de-france bonsoir
à vous également jean-michel leblanc
caire qui a donc fait amende honorable
assemblée nationale surtout sur le choix
de la destination à lille voilà qui est
réputé plutôt pour pour sa fête et ses
excentricités je reconnais une
symbolique je la regrette at il dit
c'était maladroit ou c'est une faute
politique pierre cabaret
c'est un choix c'est un choix de lieux
de vacances alors j'entends bien que on
aurait sûrement en tant que français
préféré qu'il passe ses vacances à la
baule mais sap a été son choix donc ils
riaient vous le regrettez oui
écoutez dont je crois que il faut pas
faire une affaire d'une chose pareille
un lieu de vacances cette année de
vacances un choix c'est un choix
d'ailleurs il reste dans un choix tout à
fait logique puisqu'il est à moins de
deux heures de paris et s'y est
disponible puisque la preuve il a été
interviewé mais je crois que en pleine
pandémie on a besoin d'autre chose comme
comme sujet et surtout sur l'éducation
moi je préférerais su parler d'un sujet
comme l'orientation pour dans
l'éducation l'orientation des enfants
des élèves qui on va pas faire 80 %
bacheliers moi c'est mon dada vous savez
l'orientation et vrd
des études courtes pour pouvoir orienter
les jeunes vers des métiers et des
métiers où il se réalise c'est vrai
qu'il faut pas être naïf c'était la
veille de la rentrée scolaire un
protocole sanitaire qui est arrivés très
tardivement dans la soirée certains
parents en ont fait l'expérience de
lundi matin à 8 heures je vous le
confirme franck louvrier le général de
gaulle avait raison au ministre va ça
passe ses vacances en bretagne et c'est
tout malheureusement surtout je pense
qu'il est assez amateur de ré ce qu'on
fait n'est plus aussi de votre
opérateur de l'île de bréhat donc juste
non mais au delà de la forme et du fond
la difficulté si vous voulez c'est que
symboles et les efforts et il présidera
lui que le c'est bien parce qu'il fait
des manifestations aussi à forte
connotation symbolique et le fêtait ses
15 ministres malheureusement pour lui
d'abord quand il est muni de la
république française c'est bien qu'ils
aillent en france pour la simple et
bonne raison c'est que nous sommes la
première destination au monde et que
lorsque vous représentez la république
eh bien vous allez en france peut-être
ça dure que je
suis pas sûr qu'il ait retrouvé du
soleil au delà de ça je pense que c'est
un symbole qui est important et puis
derrière tout ça qu'est-ce que ça
traduit parce qu'enfin ne se sont pas
les hommes politiques qui jouent les
femmes politiques qui ont réagi les
premiers ce sont notamment les agents de
l'éducation nationale ils ont été très
choqués parce que derrière ça traduit
une forme de désordre de désordres qu'a
eu sur ce protocole qui a été annoncé au
dernier moment dans la presse sans être
informée et en informer les enseignants
et donc de ce fait là je pense que au
delà du symbole qui est fort il ya aussi
derrière tout ça une désorganisation qui
dure depuis quelque temps notamment dans
l'éducation nationale mais aussi dans
notre secteur on l'a vu pour la santé et
donc traduit un énervement une
exaspération des personnes qui
travaillent et qui estime que c'est un
peu la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder
le vase
et c'est déplorable parce que c'est vrai
que un ministre c'est à la fois un
ministre de la république et donc il
doit à la fois porter le lourd fardeau
du symbole tout en portant bien sûr
aussi lourd fardeau de l'action en tout
cas la majorité a passé sa journée à
défendre son ministre à mes quelques
ténors politiques eux sont montés au
créneau en c'est le cas de la candidate
du rassemblement national marine le pen
est côté en fait cette désinvolture elle
dit quelque chose voyez cette
désinvolture qui consiste à à partir
passer ses vacances dans des endroits un
10 paradisiaque
démontre d'abord une forme de désintérêt
pour ce que vivent les français en
pleine campagne présidentielle et le
deuxième enseignement c'est qu'en
réalité on n'est pas confronté à une
crise sanitaire donc on est confronté
bien à
volonté politique c'est à dire que ce
qui justifie cette forme d'agitation de
la part du gouvernement en terme de
votes du pass notamment vaccinale et de
multiplication des protocoles n'est pas
une raison sanitaire car si c'était une
raisons sanitaires je suppose que
monsieur blanc caire ne serait pas sur
les plages d'ibiza les doigts de pied en
éventail
étendu sauce et marine le pen a compris
que jean michel blanquer a été un petit
peu devenu un maillon faible du
gouvernement c'est l'homme à battre et
c'est une aubaine finalement pour
l'opposition à trois mois de la
présidentielle et pour marine le pen
notamment
pu écouter ce qui est certain c'est que
ce n'est pas l'opposition qui est
responsable des destinations de vacances
de noël du ministre de l'éducation
nationale emmanuel macron à savoir
refusant les chèques bancaires lorsque
ce qui est ce qu'il faut retenir ce qui
est important c'est que comme on l'a dit
la politique crs quand même l'art du
symbole sur un certain nombre de choses
évidemment des actions des décisions à
prendre mais il ya énormément de choses
qui se passent au niveau du symbole et
c'est vrai que quand on président de la
république qui hystérise complètement la
crise sanitaire à des fins politiques
tout le monde aura compris notamment
avec ce pass vaccinale qui est d'une
utilité mais total énormément de
spécialistes le disent notamment le
médecin en berne a rajeuni et qui a été
à votre antenne il ya quelques jours et
donc si vous voulez quand on a un
président qui nous dit que finalement
c'est la guerre rien ne va plus on ne
contrôle plus rien et qu'au même moment
en effet on a un tas ses ministres et
non non pas un des moindres parce que
c'est celui de l'éducation nationale et
on sait à quel point la rentrée a été
difficile non seulement pour les parents
d'élèves pour les élèves mais aussi pour
les enseignants les personnels les
établissements scolaires et bien qui
pendant ce moment là était en train de
se détendre tranquillement à noël
évidemment le symbole il est terrible
pour le gouvernement et on voit bien que
il ne prend absolument pas au sérieux
les français dans ce domaine là bien
cabaret je revois tout votre masque jeu
les 2 infligé cette saison les grosses
sanitaire est vraiment et c'est vraiment
dans d'abord il faut quand même un peu
revenir sur terre un des doigts de pied
en éventail abissa moi je connais pas
cette île mais je pense pas qu'à noël on
met les pieds en éventail sur la plage
non je crois que on n'a rien d'autre à
proposer que des polémiques alors ça oui
effectivement les
deux red bull et le front national n'a
aucun autre sujet que la polémique parce
que finalement il n'y a jamais de
propositions
quant aux élèves vous êtes bien ennuyé
les ait l'air parce que chaque fois que
pécresse propose une chose mc on l'a
déjà vu dans ce jeu vous
madame pécresse oui excusez moi je crois
qu'elle m'en voudra pas non plus sérieux
rection ça mais aussi dans le nord mais
c'est vrai excusez moi je reconnais que
madame pécresse
effectivement à une une fonction
importante sur la région et quelques
elle dit des choses importantes sur
l'éducation d'ailleurs puisque la moitié
des lycées sont à refaire actuellement
donc je trouve que l'argent nécessaire
il est au delà de toute polémique donc
aujourd'hui on a quoi on a une polémique
sur le masque on arrivait mieux
quelqu'un peut dire dans huit jours ce
qui peut arriver dans 15 jours mais
dîtes le alors dans ces cas-là engagez
vous mais si vous engagez et ça réussit
pas au moins ayez le
l'honnêteté de le reconnaître
ça c'est important
donc on est dans une période de pandémie
l'économie on n'a jamais lâché l'école
on l'a toujours souhaité la laisser
ouverte c'est la santé c'est vacciner
soigner sauver donc à part ça le reste
de l'opposition c'est toujours
l'opposition il faut absolument peau
limitées sur des sujets franchement que
blanc caire soit à ibiza qu'il roule en
clio ou en toyota qu'il mais quelle
importance au niveau des français quelle
importance je je je comprends pas alors
c'est le symbole faut pas exagérer non
plus symbole des symboles de la
république
non je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'exagération et vous le savez cette
celi effectivement essayé de pousser
quelque chose qui ne vaut pas la peine
quand vous avez fait la composition
c'est dix fois mieux mais dix fois mieux
sur les qu'on va laisser répond franck
louvrier sur les propositions m'enfin
pas s'empêcher regardez ce qu'ils
message du député l ère du pas de calais
pierre henri dumont regardez ce qui
n'empêche si jean michel blanquer avez
suivi nos conseils il aurait pu rester
une semaine de plus à ibiza
être candidates
ont déjà mordu manqué un petit peu
taquin non répond me dire c'était une
proposition il est vrai madame valérie
pécresse en l'occurrence de
éventuellement donner la possibilité de
rouvrir une semaine plus tard ce qui
aurait permis peut-être de mieux
s'organiser
et éventuellement de pouvoir avertir au
moins les 20 millions de personnes
concernées par cette rentrée scolaire
qui s'est pas c'est pas c'est pas rien
dans un pays de pouvoir essayer de gérer
ça au mieux mais au-delà de ça moi je
pense que d'abord la réaction
pavlovienne de la démission systématique
n'est pas utile est vraiment là me font
pressants les semaines ça ne fait pas
avancer les choses mais la difficulté
est et le fond du problème il est très
simple c'est que quand vous êtes
ministre de la république vos faits et
vos gestes sont très importants bien sûr
que vos actes et vos propositions sont
essentielles sur toi mais à 83 jours du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous avez comme devoir
bien sûr comme quand vous êtes ministre
surtout quand voulait depuis cinq ans
parce qu'en l'occurrence on peut pas
dire que monsieur blanc caire et du
nouveau monde il a eu une expérience
auparavant et il avait cette expérience
pendant cinq ans il faut prendre en
compte toutes les émotions du pays est
aujourd'hui la simple attitude qui doit
avoir c'est de dire qu'il a fait une
erreur et puis et puis voilà et la page
sera tournée mais essayez d'expliquer
l'inexplicable
si d'excuser l'inexcusable et en
l'occurrence je pense que ça ne sert à
rien d'essayer d'avoir raison lorsque
tout le monde vous dit que vous avez
tort et et malheureusement la situation
elle est là c'est dommage et c'est
dommage pour tous ceux qui travaillent
difficilement je pense dans nos dans nos
établissements scolaires qui ont une
rentrée compliquée parce que il est vrai
que les protocoles qui ont été imposées
sont pas toujours compréhensible il est
vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'hésitations
du gouvernement vous parliez des masques
on parle aussi de l'ensemble des mesures
qui ont été prises qui parfois ont donné
le sentiment qu'ils avaient des
allers-retours et 12 a fait que en plus
de ça vous avez un ministre qui donne le
sentiment d'être un peu en distance yale
alors il est vrai peu télétravail est
important mais là c'est un distant ciel
qui en dehors de nos frontières et donc
de ce fait là choc une bonne partie de
la population bien sûr qu' il n'y a pas
de quoi en faire un livre est un roman
mais les symboles ça compte et vous le
savez très bien parce que lorsque le
président de la république fait des
manifestations à forte teneur symbolique
vous êtes les premiers à applaudir et
est donc le fêtait ses clubs
malheureusement pour lui et pour
l'ensemble des personnels de l'éducation
nationale il a fait une erreur il faut
l'admettre et je pense que si ce soir il
intervient sur une chaîne de télévision
c'est sans doute aussi parce qu'il a le
sentiment que l'erreur est là et qu'il
faut essayer de la corriger on réécoute
et justement les réactions de yannick
jadot suivi de mathilde panneaux à la
france insoumise qui demandent le départ
du ministre
au lieu de préparer avec les enseignants
et les parents d'élèves une rentrée sous
qu'ovide lui ministres organisé un coup
médiatique les pieds dans le sable ce
niveau de mépris et d'irresponsabilité
n'est pas acceptable je demande de
nouveau la démission de jean michel
blanc coeur trop c'est trop jean michel
blanquer air doit démissionner
gaëtan du soc et c'est pas devenu un
petit peu tout de même le bouc émissaire
du gouvernement on a vu un jean michel
blanquer s'affronter un petit peu avec
le ministre de la santé après tout il a
certainement eu l'aval de sa hiérarchie
pour partir en vacances jean michel
blanquer
tout lui tombe dessus
si vous voulez les problèmes internes au
gouvernement et de qui finalement arrive
à tirer la couverture davantage à lui ne
m'intéresse pas vraiment et saas je
laisse ça plutôt au gouvernement et à la
gestion figurant de ses équipes du du
président de la république mais il faut
bien retenir une chose c'est que si les
vacances deux ans michel blanc caire ont
fait couler tant d'encre aujourd'hui et
si on en parle encore ce soir sur votre
plateau c'est tout simplement parce que
les protocoles de rentrée scolaire aura
été un véritable fiasco qu'on a eu en
moins d'une semaine trois protocoles
différents qui se sont enchaînés que ça
a été un calvaire est un enfer aussi
bien je le répète pour les élèves que
pour les professeurs que pour les
parents d'élèves qui n'arrivait plus à
s'y retrouver que tout ça a été fait
comme d'habitude depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire de façon très arbitraire
très verticale de la part de l'état sans
aucune concertation des principaux
intéressés à savoir les acteurs locaux
non seulement de l'enseignement mais
aussi je pense à tous ces élus locaux à
tous ce maillage associatif qui pourtant
ont été très bienveillant et très utile
notamment lors du tout premier
confinement quand il s'agissait de venir
on est de répondre aux manquements de
l'état sur un certain nombre de
dispositions comme notamment la mise en
place de masques donc si vous voulez
encore une fois c'est l'échec d'abord de
la politique et du protocole de rentrée
de jean michel blanquer qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il y à polémique en effet
la polémique s'est pas tu verses pas
l'alpha et l'oméga d'un débat politique
ni l'alpha et l'oméga d'un engagement
politique bien entendu mais ça traduit
quand même un malaise et ce malaise
c'est ce fossé considérable qu'il y as
entre la tête de l'état d'un côté et le
peuple de l'autre je pense que l'un ne
comprend plus l'autre et j'espère qu
évidemment ça se traduira par un
réassort ou du moins un sursaut
politique et électoral dans le cadre des
élections présidentielles ça c'est vrai
que c'est un reproche qui est souvent
fait au delà de cette polémique un qui
peut être vaine aux yeux de certains ce
côté hors sol des manières dacron lui
même de son gouvernement par rapport aux
vraies préoccupations des français je
pense que le côté leurs soldes c'est de
s'occuper de sujets polémiques qui sont
les neurones qui n'intéresse pas les
français
ont estimé qu'il faisait bien son
travail peut-être qu'on l'attaquerait
pas à ce point sur peut-être cette
goutte d'eau vous m'avez dit emmanuel
macron et jean michel drucker je pense
que les deux font extrêmement bien leur
travail vraiment sincèrement jean michel
blanquer ça fait cinq ans qu'il est là
c'est le ministre de l'éducation qui
restait le plus longtemps emmanuel
macron on a traversé une crise il a
dirigé notre pays est tenu le gouvernail
chaque fois qu'il ya eu un coup de riz
donc non ce que ce que je crois surtout
c'est que imaginons qu'on ait écouté
madame pécresse et qu'on est réouvert
les écoles une semaine après la
désorganisation dans les familles de sur
les gens qui il ya eu quand même 70 %
des élèves il ya 30 % d'élèves manquant
bien 70% pour ses 70 % alors dans ces
cas là il y a plus d'école comment font
les parents c'est difficile je vous
entends bien sûr les masques sur les
marche avant marche arrière assez faible
sur mais c'est difficile c'est difficile
de à la fois satisfaire et à la fois
contraindre par des mesures sanitaires
c'est très compliqué
donc c'est normal que les gens ne soient
pas très satisfait et imaginons attrape
emmanuel macron à trois mois de la
présidentielle on voit une légère baisse
dans les sondages même s'il réussit à
chaban nra qui aurait pu rattraper
emmanuel macron c'est justement de ne
pas s'impliquer à ce point dans ces
mesures sanitaires et dans cette crise
ça ça aurait pu le rattraper maintenant
je crois que personne je pense que
personne ne peut revendiquer le fait de
pouvoir faire mieux que peut-être égal
mais pas mieux on fait les choses en
période de pandémie une pandémie c'est
pas une épidémie donc c'est c'est
vraiment l'essence même de la chose
évidemment c'est pas facile évidemment
c'est facile pour personne évidemment
c'est pas facile pour les élèves qui
rentrent qui voient leurs petits
camarades qui porte à maze qui porte
plus de masques qui évidemment rien
n'est simple mais est ce que vous croyez
que c'est plus simple que de dire on
reporte d'une semaine et d'ailleurs si
jamais on avait reporté d'une semaine et
que on aurait dit mais évidemment
emmanuel blanc pierre e jean michel
blanquer air pardon
c'est drôle comme la fif et mme jean
michel blanquer et ivy ça alors
évidemment ça la range de reporter d'une
semaine eh bien non vous voyez on tient
les on tient les rênes et je crois
qu'elles sont bien tenues franck
andrieux
moi je suis les conseillers de jute ils
sont aussi des heures voilà qu'on a pu
faire mais c'était il ya 15 ans mais
au-delà de ça qu'on se connaît on est
face à une situation assez simple en fin
de compte c'est que
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
était un joker au début du gouvernement
il en est devenu là je dirais un roddick
a et c'est la traduction d'un
gouvernement et d'un exécutif épuisés
qu'ils s'en doute n'a plus la réalité du
contact avec ce qui se passe dans le
pays et pour réagir comme ça je pense
qu'à un moment donné bon voilà c'est ce
qui fait que la démocratie elle est
saine afin d'aller vers le changement et
le changement ça va être bien sûr de
nouvelles équipes et j'espère aussi une
nouvelle majorité mais c'est ça en fin
de compte c'est que on le voit bien sur
des décisions aussi majeur sur les
prises de position aussi symbolique on
fait des erreurs après cinq ans de
responsabilités
que ça prouve quand même que tout ça
fait que ça demande beaucoup de
changements je voudrais vous montrer un
sondage
73 % des sondés trouvent le climat
ennuyeux parce qu'on ne parle pas des
vraies préoccupations
des français gaëtan du soucier ça vous
l'expliquez comment parce que c'est vrai
que le coc vide on ne parle que de ça là
on en fait l'expérience malheureusement
on essaye de parler d'autre chose sûre
sur cette chaîne aussi mais
certains candidats deviennent presque
transparent par moments vous le vous le
déplorez au rassemblement national vous
en avez cette même lecture
puisque la transparence des candidats
masse qui m'inquiète et vous avez
parfaitement raison de le souligner ce
soir c'est l'absence d'un véritable
débat présidentiel une véritable
campagne présidentielle on al'impression
dire c'est quand même ça fait mais on
est un peu plus de 80 jours du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle en
temps normal
c'est le sujet de l'élection au cul et
sature l'ensemble des médias et on ne
parle que de ça et de tous les sujets
qui préoccupent les français comme par
exemple le pouvoir d'achat avec encore
les prix du carburants qui ont atteint
un sommet jamais égalée par avant la à
80 jours la dernière fois que je
regardais la télé le bandeau qui avait
marqué c'était olivier et olivier
ferrand positif au qu'ovide désolé mais
l'actualité à 80 jours de l'élection
mère de toutes les élections de
l'élection présidentielle qui fixe
finalement quel avenir on décide pour
notre pays pendant cinq ans et bien de
se dire que tout ça c'est secondaire par
rapport à la contamination d'un ministre
à une maladie que finalement avec
laquelle on est obligé est contraint de
vivre maintenant et on s'est habitué à
vivre depuis deux ans bien oui
évidemment le débat présidentiel n'est
pas là mais encore possible de se
demander pourquoi la raison elle est
très simple il faut aller la chercher du
côté de l'elysée parce que c'est qui qui
est stérile justement cette crise
sanitaire c'est qui qui met de l'huile
sur le feu en disant qu'ils emmerdent
les français c'est le président de la
république parce que le président de la
république a tout intérêt à fuir le
débat de la campagne présidentielle à
fuir les allées les répondants ce
qu'attend d'eux les français sur un
grand nombre de sujets qui les
préoccupent comme le pouvoir d'achat la
sécurité l'immigration le
communautarisme pour mieux finalement se
draper de ces deux sets ce déguisement
un peu confortable et chevalier blanc de
celui qui vous protège face à un virus
qui aujourd'hui ne sont quasiment plus
moi je pense que c'est terriblement
dangereuse qui est en train de se passer
que ça va pousser énormément de français
vers l'abstention nous nous serons là
sur le terrain lançon
ddv samedi dernier nous avons lancé des
grandes campagnes de terrain sur le
marché pour aller à la rencontre des
français et leur dire de ne pas se faire
voler cette élection par la crise
sanitaire il faut que ce s'en saisissent
il faut qu'ils fassent l'élection il
faut qu'ils aillent voter s'ils tombent
dans le piège de l'abstention s'en
sortira et pierre cabaret vous avez ce
sentiment aussi que parfois la majorité
dont vous faites partir et ont participé
l'exécutif voilà un instrument les
instrumentalisent un petit peu cette
crise sanitaire parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle occupe le terrain et élections
approchent on voit moins peut-être les
autres candidats et bien sûr tout le
monde en parle donc évidemment que les
gens on parle de sujets importants quand
on parle mais je voudrais rebondir sur
l'intérêt du président que de se
déclarer candidat oui ce serait
déclarer candidat aujourd'hui sûrement
mais sa fonction et sa mission
je suis désolé mais aujourd'hui on a
intérêt à avoir un président qui
gouverne et qui se déclarent le plus
tard possible pour pouvoir gouverner le
plus longtemps possible dès qu'il sera
déclaré candidat il ne pourra plus que
difficilement gouverner on est bien
d'accord difficulté s'ils vendent eux de
faire des des contraintes 1 parce que ce
sont des contraintes que de porter un
masque que demander à des écoliers de le
faire donc aujourd'hui l'intérêt du
président son intérêt pour son élection
sa réélection s'il est candidat c'est de
se déclarer candidat mais l'intérêt de
la france et l'intérêt supérieur de la
france c'est justement d'avoir un
président qui gouverne et le plus
longtemps possible
pour sortir c'est très clair c'est que
l'exécutif joue avec le feu c'est à dire
qu'à force de essayé de lancer certains
débats sans vouloir rentrer à
l'intérieur de ces débats on l'a vu sur
l'intervention du chef de l'état dans le
parisien on l'a vu sur d'autres débats
ou en fin de compte le gouvernement est
dans une stratégie de l'évitement c'est
à dire que il essaye de faire monter les
extrêmes pour pouvoir essayer de miser
sur un deuxième tour face à des extrêmes
et donc de ce fait la joue
la provocation sans vouloir rentrer sur
le fond du débat vous savez je pense que
le principal responsable de tout ça bien
sûr c'est le chef de l'état c'est lui
qui ne souhaite pas mettre les mains
dans le cambouis du débat et c'est vrai
que alors que normalement il devrait
être candidat aujourd'hui que quasiment
toutes les représentations politiques
ont un candidat le fait est même
plusieurs parfois le fêtait ses que lui
n'y en a pas et c'est la majorité
sortante et c'est là je pense que j'ai
une responsabilité directe et
personnelle du chef de l'état dans dans
la pauvreté du débat merci franck
louvrier merci également à gaëtan du
sausset et à pierre cabaret d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur ce plateau
et pendant ce temps le kobe 19 continuer
à nous mettre sous tension les hôpitaux
français à un plus de 26 mille cinq
cents personnes sont actuellement
hospitalisées une hausse de 750 patients
en moins d'une journée nouveau record
également c'est pour ça qu'on en parle
pour sur les contaminations plus de 460
4000 cas recensés en 24 heures une
progression fulgurante donc sous la
poussée de mikron petite lueur d'espoir
tout de même ce variant extrêmement
contagieux serait moins dangereux on
sait que les précédents emmanuel macron
qui se prépare pour son grand oral
européen lancement de la présidence
française du conseil de l'ue prévue
demain le président présentera les
priorités de paris devant les
eurodéputés un discours suivi d'une
séance de questions-réponses cette
intervention depuis strasbourg sera
scruté après à moins de trois mois donc
de cette présidentielle même s'il n'est
pas encore déclaré ses opposants lui
reprochent de se servir de cette tribune
européenne pour faire campagne et le
parlement européen qui a d'ailleurs élu
aujourd'hui nouvelle présidente pour
deux ans il s'agit de la maltaise
roberta mais de solal succède à
l'italien david sassoli décédé le 11
janvier dernier
élection à la majorité absolue malgré le
profil très contesté de la nouvelle
présidente yoann tritz
quarante deux ans après la française
simone veil c'est pour la troisième fois
une femme qui prend la tête du parlement
européen roberta mais de ceux-là a été
élu avec 458 voix sur 705 une écrasante
majorité
elle devient ainsi la plus jeune
présidente de l'hémicycle de strasbourg
alors que cette élection pourrait être
un symbole les prises de position de la
membre du parti populaire européen parti
conservateur du parlement sont loin
d'être similaire à celle de son aîné
certains opposants au sein de
l'institution le déplore une anti
avortement à la tête du parlement
européen c'est un symbole terrible 42
ans après simone veil est alors que des
milliers de polonaise des fils dans les
rues depuis plus d'un an pour défendre
le droit à disposer de leur corps la
honte
nous ne voulons pas une femme anti ivg
mais une femme féministe à la tête du
parlement européen une opposition
farouche à l'avortement alors même que
la maltaise se déclare féministe est
engagé en faveur des lgbt malte est
d'ailleurs le dernier bastion de l'ue à
l'interdire totalement roberta mais de
cela c'est fait aussi remarquer en
s'abstenant lors d'une séance de vote
pour une résolution qui devait
criminaliser les violences faites aux
femmes face aux craintes d'une partie
des parlementaires européens la nouvelle
présidente a dû se défendre au public au
sujet de la santé et des droits sexuels
et reproductifs
ce parlement européen ait été sans
ambiguïté il a demandé à plusieurs
reprises que ces droits soient mieux
protégés pas plus tard que le mois
dernier nous avons souligné que l'accès
au centre d'accueil était un élément
essentiel pour atteindre la parité et
éliminer la violence sexiste c'est la
position de cette institution et je peux
confirmer
je m'engage envers vous tous que c'est
la position que je vais défendre comme
je lé déjà fait en tant que vice
présidente une fois qu'on m'a confié la
présidence de cette institution
s'ajoutent à cela des critiques apparues
lorsque roberta médecin l'a soutenu la
place financière de son pays lors des
panamas peppers la révélation de fraude
fiscale de grande ampleur
ce type de position est pourtant
totalement en contradiction avec
plusieurs partis présents au sein de la
coalition qui l'a élu comme renaissance
dont fait partie la république en marche
ou encore les socialistes de s&d ils ont
semble-t-il mis de côté leurs valeurs
pour respecter un accord datant de 2010
9 qui assurait du soutient un candidat
du parti populaire européen lors de ces
élections tout ça dans le but de garder
la mainmise sur l'organe européen
l'arrivée au pouvoir de la femme de 43
ans mais saluée par plusieurs
personnalités politiques notamment par
valérie pécresse candidate les
républicains à la présidentielle
amicales félicitations à roberta mezzo
la nouvelle présidente du parlement
européen
troisième femme à occuper cette fonction
depuis simone veil je travaillerai main
dans la main avec elle pour une europe
démocratique prenant compte des
aspirations des nation et des citoyens
c'est un signal fort envoyé aux pays de
l'union celle d'une droitisation de
l'institution et direction le royaume
uni où boris johnson tente de sauver sa
peau le premier ministre britannique est
toujours empêtré dans le scandale et
soirées arrosées c'était en mai 2020 on
plaint confinement à londres aujourd'hui
il défend une nouvelle fois avoir été
prévenus qu'une fait contraire aux
règles anti coville était organisée
morrison pensé que c'était une réunion
de travail
je peux vous dire catégoriquement que
personne ne m'a dit et que personne n'a
dit que c'était quelque chose qui était
contraire aux règles que c'était une
violation des règles du code vide ou que
nous faisions quelque chose qui n'était
pas un événement de travail parce que
franchement je ne pense pas que je
puisse imaginer pourquoi diable il
aurait pu aller de l'avant ou qu'il
aurait été autorisé à aller de l'avant
mon souvenir de cet événement comme je
les dis et d'être sorti dans le jardin
pendant environ 25 minutes pour ce que
je pensais implicitement être un
événement de travail et de parler aux
personnels de remercier le personnel je
ne me souviens pas exactement du nombre
de personnes présentes mais j'y suis
resté environ 25 minutes
je regrette profondément et amèrement
que cela soit arrivé et je ne peux que
renouveler mes excuses à la fois sa
majesté et au pays pour les erreurs de
jugements qui ont été faites et j'en
assume l'entière responsabilité
être à critiquer sous pression après
donc les appels à la démission boris
johnson s'apprête à faire de nouvelle
annonce une série de mesures choc pour
reconquérir le coeur des britanniques à
bilal à oiseaux
boris johnson est en mauvaise posture et
il le sait la photo booth partys c'est
soirée alcoolisée organisée dans des
bâtiments officiels du gouvernement
un scandale qui continue de faire des
dégâts le premier ministre britannique
est désormais directement menacés
pour sauver sa place johnson aurait mis
en place deux plans d'urgence baptisée
save bigdog sauver le gros chien et red
meat viande rouge objectif flatter les
députés conservateurs qui ont son destin
entre leurs mains une demi douzaine
d'entre eux exigent ouvertement son
départ et une vingtaine ont rédigé des
lettres de défiance en vue de déclencher
un vote de confiance
l'opération save big dog consisterait à
sacrifier plusieurs responsables en leur
faisant endosser la responsabilité de
ces soirées le directeur du personnel de
downing street et le secrétaire privé de
boris johnson serait visé une manoeuvre
jugée grossière par l'opposition red
meat de son côté aurait pour but
d'abolir à la fin du mois les
restrictions sanitaires en vigueur
depuis décembre dernier comme le
télétravail ou le port du masque
obligatoire dans les transports autre
mesure de cette opération demandez à la
royal navy de bloquer l'arrivée des
migrants sur les côtes britanniques
jugé comme une tentative désespérée de
faire oublier les bourses partys le
premier ministre souhaiterait supprimer
d'ici 2028 la redevance de la bbc qui
revient aujourd'hui à 190 euros par
foyer proposition séduisante mais pour
l'instant aucun plan de financement du
diffuseur n'a été présentée pour pallier
à cette perte
l'avenir de boris johnson reste très
incertain et ce ne sont pas ces
propositions qui semble pouvoir l'aider
40% des électeurs conservateurs
souhaitent son départ le rapport de la
haute commissaire chargée de faire la
lumière sur ces faits est interdite
pourraient tous précipités il devrait
être rendu en fin de semaine
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis les sisters au royaume uni avec
alister jaune ce professeur agrégé en
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
et alister jones bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous boris johnson qui dément donc
avoir participé à une fête un an mais
2020 son ancien conseiller dominique
cumines sein la cus pourtant l'ami le
cerveau de sa campagne devenu finalement
son pire ennemi comment être sûr que que
l'on n'est pas ici dans une histoire de
de basse vengeance
il s'agit probablement d'une vengeance
mais cela ne veut pas dire que ce n'est
pas vrai de munich à 2 mins a affirmé
qu'il jurerait sous serment que tout ce
qu'il a dit est vrai il cela suggère
qu'il a d'autres informations dont nous
ne sommes pas encore au courant
cette situation tourne à la comédie
christiansen demion avoir participé à
une fête puis l'a dit mais il est
peut-être une défaite d'un total n'était
qu'une avait pas à l'encontre des règles
et puis il a lancé une enquête pour voir
s'il y avait eu des rassemblements donc
sa position devant une fusion entre une
eau fragile et à ces accusations par
dominique comics ne font qu'aggraver la
chose alors peut-être que dominique
commune c'est prêt a témoigné sous
serment mais boris johnson aussi
finalement est ce que ça pourrait lui il
lui coûter son poste
si on savait qu'il allait mais ça
s'avérait qu'il avait menti bien sûr un
s'il ya la moindre preuve que pour exxon
a menti au parlement alors il devra
démissionner où il sera chassé de son
poste c'est le pire des ligues que l'on
puisse commettre en tant que premier
ministre que de mentir au parlement
il a menti à la population c'est certain
il a même menti à la reine donc son
bilan et qu'ils mangent souvent
c'est là et qui éprouvait dans ces
emplois précédents en tant que
journaliste en tant que maire de londres
ainsi qu'en tant que secrétaire des
affaires étrangères et en tant que
député donc il a déjà par le passé le
manipuler la vérité afin de se faire
bien paraître
il affirma il s'agissait de réunions de
travail je ne sais pas si parmi vous
téléspectateurs
beaucoup amènent leurs femmes à une
réunion de travail on boit de l'alcool
dans le jardin de sa maison pour moi
c'est
vraiment suspicieux et l'opinion
générale et qu'il a menti on qu'on l'a
découvert et qu'il ne devrait pas trop
rester longtemps premier ministre après
cela pour l'opinion britannique
c majeur justement de savoir si boris
johnson alioui a menti oui ou non a dit
la vérité ou finalement on va l'épinglé
pour d'autres raisons que cela et ça a
été la goutte d'eau
c'est tout à fait la goutte d'eau qui
fait déborder le vase
ce qui est intéressant
c'est que le public et même personne
parce qu'il semblait excentrique ne
serait ce qu'avec sa coiffure
qui ont considéré qu'il ne faisait pas
partie des élus
pensaient qu'il s'agissait de quelqu'un
de simple avec lequel pouvait boire une
bière avec la pandémie
on s'est rendu compte que ce type de
personne n'est pas du tout art briller
pour diriger le pays mais quand même
sympa la situation est devenue si graves
qu'ils cherchent autour de lui n'importe
qui à qui faire bloquer l porter le
chapeau
le plus il fait cela de plus cela met en
colère les gens
il est encore beaucoup de personnes dans
les pays qui pensent que c'est un jour
en premier le ministre est lui a fait un
très bon travail avec le président par
exemple et par la clé grâce à la
campagne de vaccination mais ces
arguments commencent à s'user et la
population commence à être lassé
de nombreuses personnes
témoigner que ne pas avoir pu dire leurs
adieux à des proches alors qu'il
m'aurait
comme on m'aime ou boris johnson
faisait la fête donc le public en a
assez et ce qu'il s'en aille alors il ya
néanmoins une opération qui a été lente
ces opérations cessent big dog a
autrement dit l'opération sauvé le gros
chien est ce que ça peut fonctionner
non
l'idée de l'opération sauvé le gros
chien c'est que boris johnson essaie de
sauver sa peau en d'autres temps à faire
porter le chapeau à quelqu'un d'autre là
le premier candidat c'est martin
reynolds smith et après des principales
qui a envoyé un email à des centaines de
personnes
exécutant à une rencontre ce seuil
atteint de ce truc
où les rencontres et les fortunes tête
interdite
martin reynolds n'aurait pas vraiment à
muscat sur
l'accord explicite de presse personne il
semblerait que martine raynaud ce qu'est
ce que d'être viré pour cela mes plus
beaux restes en scène essaye de là mais
d'autres personnes donc plus le spi est
en colère contre lui car il n'accepte
pas ses responsabilités
même si on peut dire je me suis excusé
la rue mais à mon sens un grand danger
de ces excuses n'étaient pas sincères
il s'agissait pour lui souvent de venir
vous avez pensé que photo que de
s'excuser pour ses actions de
suffisance ici donc je pense qu'il va
la question est qui va le remplacer
le parti conservateur a sans doute
quelques candidats à linda mais jusqu'à
ce qu'il soit remplacé il continuera
tant bien que mal en tant que premier
ministre à suivre donc merci à leicester
jones professeur agrégé en politique
d'avoir été avec nous pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
la crise du crédit elle cherche toujours
une porte de sortie diplomatique ce soir
la porte parole de la maison blanche
estime je cite que la russie peut
attaquer l'ukraine à tout moment fin de
citation et prévient que washington
n'exclut aucune option pour répondre à
une telle attaque pour éviter l'escaladé
une rencontre entre le chef de la
diplomatie américaine anthony blinken et
son homologue russe sergueï lavrov aura
lieu vendredi à genève après un
entretien téléphonique aujourd'hui les
précisions de notre correspondante
verhaeghe hoffman à moscou
après genève bruxelles nouveaux échanges
entre les états unis et la russie cette
fois c'est à l'initiative américaine qui
a eu lieu une conversation téléphonique
entre le secrétaire d'état américain
anthony blinken et son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov au sommaire des
propositions russes dans le domaine de
la sécurité en europe mais aussi de la
situation et crée nien les chefs de
diplomatie se sont mis d'accord pour en
tête à tête dans un avenir proche une
rencontre qui pourrait intervenir le 21
janvier à genève selon la maison blanche
sergueï lavrov a de nouveau souligné les
points fondamentaux des traités
bilatéraux avec les états unis et au
sujet d' accord avec l'otan précédemment
transmis par la russie fixant les
garanties juridiques de la sécurité de
la russie dans le cadre du principe de
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité
approuvé par tous les pays euro
atlantique
la russie a pour sa part confirmé qu'il
était impératif que washington fournisse
le plus rapidement possible des
commentaires sur papier article par
article concernant les documents
mentionnés dans le contexte de la
situation tendue dans le sud est de
l'ukraine le ministre a exhorté le
secrétaire d'état à ne pas multiplier
les spéculations sur la prétendue
agression russe qui serait en cours de
préparation mais a forcé les autorités
de kiev à remplir pleinement les accords
de minsk le chef de la diplomatie
américaine anthony blinken a quant à lui
plaidé en faveur de la voie diplomatique
pour mettre fin à la crise entre la
russie et l'ukraine selon le porte
parole du département d'état ned price
du côté de l'otan son secrétaire général
et jens stoltenberg
a déclaré avoir invité la russie et tous
les alliés de l'otan a participé à une
série de réunions du conseil russie otan
dans un avenir proche lors de ces
entretiens il s'agira pour rien
stoltenberg de répondre à certaines
préoccupations de l'alliance mais aussi
d'écouter les préoccupations de la
russie afin d'essayer de trouver une
solution conjointe de sortie de crise
pour en parler nous sommes avec xavier
moreau fondateur de strates paul vous ce
soir xavier moreau merci d'être avec
nous plusieurs réunions donc un la
semaine dernière avec lé numéro deux de
la diplomatie on en a d'ailleurs parlé
ici même sur ce plateau avec la fermeté
mais mais un ton quand même car n'est ce
soir ses déclarations du porte parole de
la maison blanche la russie peut
attaquer l'ukraine à tout moment
pourquoi une telle déclaration
maintenant on va écouter non c'est pas
maintenant en fait on entend ça depuis à
peu près deux mois mme depuis le début
du mois de novembre en fait pour être
précis
on entend ça beaucoup dans la presse
américaine et je pense qu'il s'agit pour
la maison blanche de donner le change à
la fois pour son électorat démocrate et
en même temps pour les élites de
démocrates qui ne comprennent pas trop
ce qui se passe puisque qu'ils
attendaient de joe biden qui soit le
vengeur de ce qui s'était passé avec
donald trump et depuis depuis juin de
l'année dernière on s'aperçoit que la
russie et les etats unis essayent de
trouver une solution diplomatique donc
on continue à avoir des déclarations des
deux côtés d'ailleurs c'est pas
seulement du côté américain mais du côté
russe mais quand on regarde en fait dans
les faits les choses avancent plutôt
plutôt bien
chacun fait fait un effort le le sénat
les démocrates ont pas voté des
sanctions que réclamait le républicain
tom cruise au sénat donc le congrès
n'appliquera pas de sanctions
automatiques contre la russie donc ça
veut dire que joe biden le voulait
puisqu'il a obtenu le soutien de sa
majorité au congrès et d'un autre côté
les russes viennent d'arrêter un groupe
de hackers qui était responsable du
piratage du 'pipeline' coloniale en mai
donc je pense qu'au contraire toutes ces
déclarations plus ou moins agressives
sont là pour cacher le fait que la
russie et que les intérêts de la russie
à moyen terme c'est-à-dire d'investir
dans le donbass pour le développer et de
joe biden à court terme c'est à dire les
élections mi-mandat qui auront lieu au
mois de novembre et bien les deux
intérêts convergent donc ni l'une ni
l'autre des grandes puissances n'ont
besoin d'un conflit en ukraine cela dit
on va encore entendre des déclarations
comme on a entendu en fait ce qu'il nous
répète c'est ce qu'on a entendues au
printemps de l'année dernière on a eu un
oeil y secondes étaient tous merci parce
qu'on est en pleine séance de
négociations brinken élèves vont encore
se rencontrer vendredi ça veut dire
qu'en gros on fait une forme de
communication pour satisfaire les
opinions publiques et dans le fond vous
nous dites ce soir les choses avancent
et on va plutôt vers une désescalade
contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre
oui dans dans les faits en fait si vous
regardez concrètement les étapes qui
sont en fait en dehors des discours vous
regardez les faits ça avance plutôt bien
j'ai incité deux choses particulièrement
concrète si vous les états unis ne
peuvent pas se permettre d' une guerre
dans l'ukraine que la russie
remporterait en deux semaines et qui
provoquerait l'effondrement de l'ukraine
et contre lequel les états unis ne
pourraient absolument rien faire donc ça
veut dire que joe biden se présenterait
aux élections de mi-mandat qui sont déjà
très mal parti pour le parti démocrate
avec un des plus gros échecs
depuis depuis la réunification de la
crimée où depuis la guerre en géorgie
donc ce serait une véritable catastrophe
pour pour le parti démocrate donc joe
biden ne peut pas se permettre une
guerre en ukraine et la russie n'en a
pas besoin parce que elle veut investir
dans la partie qui est
contrôlé par les républiques populaires
dans le donbass et donc elle n'a pas
besoin d'une guerre non plus sinon tous
ces investissements n'aboutiront à rien
il n'empêche elle a réussi exige
toujours on parlait souvent de cette
fameuse ligne rouge à l'engagement de
l'otan à ne pas s'élargir
l'entrée de l'ukraine dans l'otan
toujours pas de réponse y a pas de quoi
s'alarmer
non parce que de toute manière ni
l'ukraine ni la géorgie ne peuvent
rentrer de l'otan dans la mesure ils ont
des territoires contestés la géorgie à
l'abkhazie et l'ossétie du sud et le
cren à au moins la crimée est en fait le
dans de basses qu'elles ne contrôlent
pas donc ça veut dire que si si jamais
le temps accepté le cren ou la géorgie
dans son dans son
dans son giron enfin comme membre de
l'otan ça veut dire qu automatiquement
par exemple la france et l'allemagne
seraient en guerre contre la russie
parce que quand vous rentrez dans une
alliance vous rentrez avec un territoire
et ça ni l'allemagne ni la france ne le
voudront donc en fait à mon avis c'est
un c'est un faux débat c'est plutôt une
manoeuvre assez habile des ruches pour
mettre les occidentaux face à la réalité
d'une situation qui leur est défavorable
et face au fait que effectivement
historiquement toutes les promesses qui
avaient été faites c'est vrai non écrite
mais
juste elle écrite aurait-elle été tenus
je ne pense pas aucune de ses promesses
n'a été n'a été tenu et donc en fait
c'est c'est plutôt une démarche assez
habile de moscou de mettre l'occident
face à ses responsabilités y compris
historique vous venez parler de paris de
berlin définitivement ces négociations
seront faites entre les russes et les
américains directement il ya eu cette
séquence de l'essai mais finalement le
dernier mot c'est à deux que ça se passe
bah écoutez vous voyez aujourd'hui sa
grille lavrov recontre s sont pour la
première fois son homologue
allemande madame barbe rock est en fait
si vous avez écouté la la conférence de
presse à l'issue de ce rendez vous c'est
ce qu'on a entendu c'est à dire que
madame mr brock parler encore de régler
le problème dans le cadre du format
normandie et sai lavrov disait mais moi
je veux bien qu'on se réunissent dans le
format normandie dont qui réunit les
présidents ukrainien russe allemand et
français mais d'abord il faut appliquer
ce qui était décidée en décembre 2019
dans ce même format c'est à dire
l'application des accords de minsk
rappelons au passage à l'allemagne à la
france que il était garant de ces
accords et que c'était à eux de faire
pression sur l'ukraine donc le la russie
et personne n'ose dire le contraire veut
réellement régler le problème ukrainien
dans le cadre des accords de minsk et
les français les allemands n'osent pas
le faire et je pense que d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'a dit sergueï lavrov dans
cette conférence de presse avec madame
barbe rock c'est que finalement les
américains une approche beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus concrète et réaliste et
volontariste de régler le problème selon
les accords de minsk que les européens
donc exit les européens et bienvenue à
la nouvelle discussion entre les deux
grandes puissances russe et américaine
justement ma dernière question est tendu
la main sur cette première rencontre
officielle entre sarria lavrov et son
homologue allemand n'a quoi doit-on
s'attendre à l'avenir on sait que les
relations n'ont pas toujours été tendres
avec le gouvernement allemand les choses
vont empirer encore davantage écoutés
oui non alors déjà les relations
n'étaient pas si mauvaises parce que si
vous souvenez la coalition précédente
c'est une coalition qui rassemblait les
chrétiens démocrates de la cdu ou et les
les sociaux démocrates du spd les deux
parties sont favorables étaient
favorables
à une bonne relation avec la russie mais
même si le disait pas ouvertement et
surtout à l'ouverture le plus rapidement
possible devant stream de là c'était la
première fois que sergueï lavrov
rencontré madame barbe qui elle est une
écologiste donc il s'est déclaré pendant
toute la campagne contre nantes stream 2
contre les énergies carbonées etc etc
qui a fait quelques déclarations sitôt
nommé aux affaires étrangères qui ont
été assez maladroite qui ont été
d'ailleurs démenties par le chancelier
scholtes donc du parti du parti
démocrate et là on a vu
on a vu surtout l'amateurisme de madame
barbe rock en fait qui visiblement n'est
pas taillé pour discuter avec sergueï
lavrov mais cela dit elle a dit quelque
chose de très intéressant puisqu'elle a
invoqué plusieurs chevaux débute son de
son discours la maison commune
européenne et ça si vous vous souvenez
c'est le discours de gorbatchev en 1985
ou en fait il essayait de créer cette
europe de pour paraphraser général de
gaulle de l'atlantique à l'oural et qui
n'avait rencontré aucun écho finalement
au sein de au sein des européens hélas
cette fois on est la situation inverse
sous scellés les allemands qui essayent
de venir chercher la russie pour créer
une europe justement extra union
européenne qui puisse
aller vers une voie pas s'y fier comme
l'espérait gorbatchev en 85 donc je
pense pas que ça change réellement le la
relation entre eux entre moscou et
berlin dans la mesure où l'allemagne des
impératifs industriels énergétiques et
elle a absolument besoin de la russie
elle absolument besoin de l'ouverture du
'pipeline' du gazoduc pas redondant
stream 2 merci beaucoup en tout cas
xavier amoureux nous avoir apporté votre
analyse restez avec nous dans quelques
instants notre débat justement on en
parle est un du pétrole du gaz du
carburant avec des vos records on va se
poser la question quelle réponse
politique emmanuel macron et il
impuissant face à cette nouvelle flambée
des carburants nos invités viendront
tenter de décrypter la situation
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
je pensais que tout le monde connaissait
déjà kim philby le plus fameux des
espions britanniques après james bond
rappelez-nous pourquoi il s'est tourné
vers le communisme il pensait que la
gauche s'étaient vendus il se disait la
démocratie la démocratie sociale ne fait
pas le travail et il a vu l'avènement
d'hitler en allemagne donc il regardait
l'union soviétique comme un bastion anti
fasciste
l'un des éléments clés selon as
concernant philby
c'est que tout le monde a sous-estimé la
force de son engagement idéologique
l'autre chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier
à son sujet et qu'il avait des capacités
extraordinaires pour la tromperie
c'était un menteur tout à fait brillant
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une surréaliste et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
les gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes eux
semblent s'est octroyé un pourboire de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens
cherchent et j'essayais de trouver des
réponses mais l étrave ainsi jamais à
oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise sans que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio on
sait si c'est grave ou si c'est pas
grave plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire le carburant qui atteint de
nouveaux records en une semaine le prix
moyen du gazole a grimpé de 3 centimes
plus de 100 tenue pour le sans plomb une
hausse qui suit celle du cours du
pétrole alors quelles réponses
politiques à cette mauvaise nouvelle
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français
emmanuel macron et il impuissant face à
ces augmentations records vous pouvez
réagir sur notre compte télégramme pour
alimenter notre débat
le prix du pétrole continue de flamber
atteint des seuils historiquement haut
et des prix records depuis 2014
conséquence d'une météo glaciale mais
aussi de tensions géopolitiques
notamment les détails avec mehdi skis et
fille et françois xavier lambert
l'or noir toujours plus rares toujours
plus prisés toujours plus cher ce mardi
le prix du baril a atteint un niveau
historique le brent et le west texas
intermediate n'ont jamais été aussi haut
depuis sept ans avec des montants fixés
entre 85 et 87 dollars
cette augmentation est liée à plusieurs
phénomènes
d'abord plusieurs productions ont été
interrompus dans les pays africains
comme au nigeria en angola ou en libye
une situation identique en équateur
tandis que la production au canada est
freinée par des températures extrêmement
froides mais pour les spécialistes il
est surtout question du rapport entre
vendeurs et acheteurs
les marchés restent concentrés sur l'
équilibre délicat entre l'offre et la
demande qui semble avoir un impact assez
importants sur les fluctuations de prix
tout au long de la reprise économique
post pandémie autres facteurs qui
accentuent l'augmentation du prix du
baril les tensions géopolitiques dans le
golfe persique notamment entre les
rebelles yéménites soutenu par l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite
mais pour d'autres spécialistes les
responsables du prix du pétrole sont les
membres de la ganisation des pays
exportateurs
seuls les membres de l'opep et leurs
alliés peuvent faire baisser les prix à
ce stade en pompant davantage de brut au
lieu de cela les pays de l'opep vont
probablement s'en tenir à leur stratégie
d'assouplissement progressive des
réductions de production car il profite
des prix élevés actuels selon de
nombreux analystes les prix du brut
pourrait dépasser des 90 dollars le
baril cette année les spécialistes de
goldman sachs se projettent même en 2023
et annonçant baril de brut à hauteur de
105 dollars
alors quelles sont les réactions
précédent record de carburant réponse au
micro de sébastien duffo alors je trouve
que franchement la hausse des carburants
bon bah c'est une peu une hérésie parce
que du coup la difficulté de la vie
future on peut pas tout payer et en ce
moment c'est très compliqué surtout avec
l'électricité et le gaz tous et toutes
ces énergies là qui comptait vraiment
cher et ça sent que les budgets sont
réduits parce que du coup avec la crise
qu'on a eue avec le co vide il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se retrouvent dans
des situations compliquées donc
et qui ne peuvent pas tout assurer donc
le carburant ça devient coûts
supplémentaires de soles 95 et 98 sans
plomb tout ça tout est cher et je monte
de plus en plus ça serait bien que
l'état fasse un petit geste oui c'est
très cher en plus en ce moment toute la
vie et coûte très très cher le niveau de
vie l'a augmentée et l'on se sort plus
si maintenant il faut augmenter le prix
de l'essence pour aller au travail et
c'est ça être de plus en plus compliqué
on évite au maximum de prendre la
voiture mais non faut que ça baisse
c'est pas possible d'avoir un pratiquant
un litre d'essence à quirin 1,70 à 1,80
sur le super
c'est un truc ses incommensurables
souvenez-vous il ya quelques années on
nous a dit non mais l'essence à 2 euros
à 10 francs personne n'en voulait là on
est carrément dans les proportions
impressionnantes c'est pas du tout
quelque chose de normal et j'avoue que
je plains ces pauvres gens qui ne
peuvent pas ou qui mettent leur plein de
de gasoil après insupportable et je vais
vous dire une chose que les gens
reviennent à se révolter comme le gilet
jaune il frontis ce sera parfait alors
comment faire face à ces prix du
carburant historiquement auquel réponse
politique emmanuel macron montre-t-il
son impuissance dans ce dossier on
attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme verte et france et place aux
débats
[Musique]
et avec nous pourrons parler en direct
par skype pierre chasserait délégué
général de 40 millions d'automobilistes
bonsoir alexis poulain éditorialistes rt
france et enfin jérôme rodriguez gilet
jaune bonsoir a tous les droits et merci
d'être avec nous on va revoir ce
graphique 1 pour bien voir l'évolution
est l'état des lieux 20 du prix du
carburant ces dernières semaines en un
mois vous le voyez les prix à la pompe
n'ont cessé d'augmenter cette semaine
donc on atteint des records on le disait
moyen le prix moyen du gaz oil a grimpé
de plus de 3 centimes pierre chasserait
on a entendu ces français s'inquiétait
la situation devient tout de même
alarmante
ils sont inquiets à juste titre les
français et ça fait quelques mois
maintenant deux années de l'association
40 millions d'automobilistes en tire la
sonnette d'alarmé on va être très clair
je vais vous dire ce qui va se passer
soit l'état prend la mesure de ce qui se
passe sur les carburants qui est la taxe
visible de toutes les taxes en france
partout où il passait le long des routes
vous voyez ces panneaux qui vous affiche
les prix des carburants soit l'état
prend la mesure où ça va sur une mesure
politique qui répond à cette attente des
français soit ils n'y vont pas si l'état
n'y va pas on risque de se retrouver
avec un mouvement social il sera
extrêmement important parce que là c'est
une ségrégation par l'argent si vous
avez l'argent pour faire le plein et
circuler si vous n'avez pas l'argent
pour faire le plein 10 fait le choix
entre vous chauffer ou pour aller au
boulot et les gamins à l'école donc on
va avoir un souci autres petits points
très importants j'entends déjà ça et là
ce petit bois de bruno le maire qui nous
dit oui mais pour chaque centime de
moins de taxes sur les carburants
ces 500 millions de moi dans l'hérault
dans les caisses de l'état alors je
salue sa rhétorique et son esprit de
conviction puisqu'il a réussi à la
convaincre les médias de cette cette
hérésie mais ce n'est pas une réalité la
situation actuelle ce n'est pas ça ce
sont des prix du baril qui s'envole et
des taxes il s'envole aussi je rappelle
que les prix du carburant sous composé
de deux taxes vous avez là telle icpe sa
cime part fixe ce fx et vous avez la tva
20 100 du prix global plus le prix du de
l'essence ont mis trop cher plus la part
de tva et short donc au contraire la
belle aubaine pour l'état plus le prix
du baril et au à chaque centime de plus
ces 500 millions encore de plus
ponctionnés sur le dos des
automobilistes
j'ai regardé quand vous entendez pierre
chasse remercier d'ailleurs pour votre
clarté et votre pédagogie nous dire soit
ils prennent les bonnes mesures on va en
parler plus en détails de ces mesures ou
alors ça va être à nouveau une grande
social d'ampleur comme on l'avait vu
avec votre mouvement
votre réaction
ça me fait rire parce que dans le
reportage que vous avez diffusé alors je
remercie monsieur charles payer si j'ai
bien compris parce que j'ai déjà souvent
tendus sur les plateaux et je sais qu'il
est très clair et j'apprécie son
discours on s'est même rencontré sur
plusieurs plateaux d'ailleurs par contre
la dernière une personne que vous avez
fait passer qui est là et qui fait appel
au gilet jaune c'est quand même
magnifique quoi vous savez ces fumeurs
buveurs de bière qui un jour ont décidé
de descendre dans la rue parce qu'il y
avait un certain problème non pas que au
niveau de l'essence mais au niveau de sa
globalité de l'énergie parce que là on
parle des voitures mais en ce moment on
est en hiver ya des gens qui ont besoin
de se chauffer le chou la prime claque
monumentale encore plus que le gasoil
parce que la deuxième chose qui me fait
rire dans votre reportage c'est les
courbes enfin de belles courbes qui sont
censés aujourd'hui intéressé les
français à défaut d'être qu'on découpe
du qu'ovide enfin des courbes qui
aujourd'hui impacte directement le
quotidien de l'ensemble des français
quand j'étais quand je vais rencontrer
monsieur sur le plateau j'avais fait
juste un rapide calcul comme ça de base
sur une voiture pour une famille vivant
en province avec 50 km 50 km de moyenne
affaires par jour on était sur un budget
de plus de 750 euros à sortir en plus
sur l'année et je ne parle que de
l'essence je poserai juste une question
parce que dans sa globalité c'est
l'ensemble de l'énergie quand on voit
que l'excédent budgétaire engrangés avec
les 57 % de hausse du prix du gaz sarah
mener 7 milliards dans les poches de
l'état français ont été repris
redistribuer 10% sous forme de primes
d'énergie que d'ailleurs j'ai toujours
entendu parler parce que pour le coup
personne dans la rue bien médias en
europe on a gagné 100 balles ni même les
deux sens d'ailleurs mais qu'est ce
qu'on a fait des 6 milliards 300
millions qui restent qu'est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui de ce pognon alors oui
je suis il ajoute parce qu'aujourd'hui
la vraie question d'un gilet jaune mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait de tout ce pognon
parce que tout ce qui a été budgété sur
l'année 2021 a été pris sur une base
d'une année passée les prix s'éclate
dans tous les sens ça fait un max de
pognon qui rendent dans les poches de
l'état on va cet argent moi
personnellement j'ai un problème avec
les impôts j'ai essayé les amants au
téléphone le dur j'ai passé une heure 17
au téléphone j'ai eu personne on fait
quoi du pognon aujourd'hui voilà pascal
il faut que les français payent si au
moins ya quelque chose qui suit derrière
je paye des taxes très bien je suis
servi publiquement quand j'ai un souci
du devis ou avec l'espace public ne sera
pas il n'y a pas de souci pour moi mais
aujourd'hui on paye des taxes déjà
horriblement cher sur un prix
horriblement cher et tout ce pognon en
danger on en voit même pas la couleur
pour du stress créé des passez moi
l'expression à sortir le puits de la
merde de l'ensemble des français parce
que la conçoit gilet jaune ou pas qu'on
soit noir ou blanc qu'on soit chrétien
ou pas ou politique ou pas le prix
d'essence vacciner ou pas le prix décent
sont le pays tous et on va le payer très
cher et on le paye déjà très cher alexis
poulain à la question justement de
savoir si emmanuel macron et donc
impuissants à cette flambée des prix du
carburant parce qu'évidemment c'est pas
la première on va d'abord regarder ces
réactions télégramme qui nous
parviennent avant de vous donner la
parole un petit peu de takhar le yoann
n'a qu'à la fin ça va vous plaire jérôme
andrien à 80 % des taxes dans le prix
c'est la seule fois où ils seraient
surpuissant emmanuel macron voilà je
vois que ça vous fait sourire tous les
trois un autre internaute ne l'y faut
bien se dire qu'il ne redescendrait pas
l'hébreu descendront pas les prix
pourquoi le ferait t-il personne ne
bouge on rappelle cette mesure annoncée
par jean castex en octobre jérôme
rodriguez nous l'a rappelé en euros à
tous les français qui gagnent moins de
2000 euros net par mois c'est vrai que
ça concerne pas tout le monde oui jérôme
rodriguez s'était passe à 200 euros pour
ceux qui gagnent moins de 2000 euros
lissée sur l'année d'où le fait qu'on
donne la prime au mois de décembre pour
ce qui concerne le gasoil je parle de la
prime énergie 200 euros qui devaient
être distribués à des français qui
déclarait moins de 10000 846 euros
d'impôts par an j'ai fait une manif il
est jaune je vous garantis que j'ai fait
demandé aux personnes qui déclarent et
moins de onze mille euros d'impôts par
an je vous garantis que 90 % des gens
ont levé la main j'aurais dit m manque
de bol les 100 euros sous le zen les
gars y en aura pour personne voilà c'est
illégal complet l expo l'instant revient
à dire que voilà emmanuel macron ce
gouvernement en tout cas s'est montré
impuissant face à cette problématique de
la flambée des prix du carburant
complètement et de toute façon c'est sur
de nombreux sujets que ce gouvernement
impuissant mais particulièrement sur le
pouvoir d'achat avec même une
déconnexion typique du gouvernement ma
chronique depuis des mois allant même
jusqu'à essayer de faire la promotion du
bilan des médailles macron sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français alors que
tous les français sont des contes qu'ils
avaient perdu en pouvoir d'achat mais
grâce à des arguties et des calculs
exceptionnel les députés de la
république en marche arrivé à défendre
ce bilan dans un an vous avez gagné
alors oui les français les plus riches
effectivement on peut être un peu gagné
la majorité des français par la hausse
du prix de logement la hausse de
l'énergie la hausse de la vie
quotidienne des produits de la vie de
tous les jours ont perdu en pouvoir
d'achat parce que les salaires n'ont pas
suivi comme d'habitude donc on voit bien
que de toute façon emmanuel macron
organise encore une fois son incapacité
son irresponsabilité à trois mois de
l'élection présidentielle il a pourtant
là une autoroute 1 pour gagner des
points dans les sondages s'il arrivait à
dire ok on va arrêter avec les chèques
s'emballe par 600 euros par là pour
colmater les brèches et on va faire une
politique de moyen à long terme
énergétique parce que non seulement
l'essence coûte cher mais on en parlait
ça va être toute l'énergie qui va coûter
cher le fuel évidemment mais l'énergie
nucléaire également edf obligés de
brader son énergie pour faire vivre une
fausse concurrence organisé par
bruxelles on a chez eux enfin là
vraiment un des murs qui risque d'être
le plus catastrophique c'est ce coût de
l'énergie dans les années qui viennent
parce que sur l'essence c'est environ
15,5 milliards de litres qui sont
consommées chaque jour par pas par la
planète et ça n'arrête pas dire qu'on
n'est pas dans une économie
où on va devenir un peu plus modérée
avec la chine qui est de plus en plus
gourmande en énergie avec l'inde
également des pays qui ont besoin
d'énergie et nous aussi donc on est dans
un une équation qui est
fatalement ne peut pas être résolu si ce
n'est par la hausse du prix et rendre
ces matières premières qui étaient
abordables les rendre inabordable en
faire un produit de luxe or désolé sans
voiture beaucoup de français ne pourront
pas aller travailler ne pourront pas
vivre tout simplement vont mourir de
faim chez eux les matières premières
vont pas pouvoir être acheminée et
derrière c'est toute la logique de
l'inflation qui se met en place
également donc non seulement ce coût à
la pompe il est hors de prix mais
l'inflation elle est aussi emmené par ce
prix de l'énergie chère et aucun enfin
et je vois encore une fois demain de
macron sera au parlement de strasbourg
ou de bruxelles au parlement européen
pour faire le beau expliquer quelle sera
sa présidence de l'union européenne
pendant quelques mois est ce que
l'europe est capable de faire une
politique énergétique la réponse est non
alors par contre pour évidemment avoir
quelques viseo stratégique sur north
stream et et empêcher ça et là des
achats d'électricité ou de gaz à bon
prix il ya plus personne faire des
champions dès les coûts d'électricité ou
de l'énergie impossible également
d'ailleurs ces mails mâcon qui a été à
la manoeuvre pour la vente d'alstom aux
américains donc on voit bien qu'il n'ya
pas de réflexion par rapport à l'énergie
en tant que moyen de souveraineté et
entend aussi que force de vie pour la
plupart des français parce que une
énergie moins chère c'est aussi une vie
meilleure bien je serai je vais vous
montrer ce graphique 1 en continu ce
soit ces prix aujourd'hui le prix du
baril qui a atteint un niveau historique
le brent et le west texas intermediate
intermediate pardon jamais été aussi
haut depuis sept ans avec des montants
fixés aujourd'hui entre 87 et et 85
dollars ça veut dire quoi concrètement
vous avez commencé à nous donner une
réponse mais tout de même c'est la
question que se posent beaucoup de monde
et c'est ce qu'on essaie de nous faire
prendre peut-être le gouvernement il une
vraie marge de manoeuvre quand vous
voyez aussi qu'il y a des effets
climatiques géopolitique nominés nominé
par jérôme redire elle je suis obligé de
poser la question pour qu'on nous donne
l'explication voilà jérôme jaffré
je ne connais pas celui-là non bien
chassé-croisé moi c'est jérôme guy m'a
qui m'a troublé voilà pierre chaze
précisé
on préfère alors passer l'humour message
adressé aux français les pas positifs
en l'état actuel
si les perspectives de reprise
économique sont à l'international en
sortie pour rené virus c'est ce qu'on
souhaite tous un branchement n'en peut
plus donc il va y avoir une utilisation
notamment français je vous rappelle
qu'en ce moment la france est en
télétravail ou une partie de la
population dans cette population bar
robe ambrée la route elle y avoir une
demande croissante en carburants qu'il
va faire mécaniquement encore monter les
prix du carburant là actuellement
pendant que nous les supari à plus de 2
euros le litre et en france aux
alentours de 20 euros 69 70 selon les
carburants je pense qu'il faut être très
clair il faut parler à la france des
provinces et expliqué que si le
gouvernement ne sait rien on aura deux
euros le litre partout et bien plus dans
les grandes villes donc c'est
insupportable on va avoir parce que
c'est quoi la conséquence c'est la
désertification des zones rurales parce
que lorsque vous êtes et bien vous
pouvez pu assumer de voiture pour partir
au travail donc vous déménagez c'est
c'est tout notre territoire et tout ce
qui fait la spécificité la richesse de
notre territoire ces campagnes ces
villes qui va être mis en balance demain
c'est parce que la voiture pareille
c'est rigolo mais il n'ya pas que ça
mais aussi en est ces gamins à l'école
les emmenait à des activités sportives
c'est aussi partir en week-end partiront
famille retrouver des amis du temps
social il faut qu'on en parle du temps
social on en a besoin aussi et tout ça
c'est le vélo cher pierre chasserait
pour partir de
mélo moi je veux bien mais je veux
l'avoir reçue avant donc c'est gelé vu
partir en campagne présidentielle je
n'ai pas lu monté sur un vélo donc
soyons réalistes ainsi dorénavant ce
qu'il faut se reprendre un peu de
pragmatisme garde cinquante solutions il
y en a qu'une donc le message qu'on va
envoyer au président de la république
idée simple il ya soit il le fait soit
il ne fait pas
de la bonne et moi qui a chassé il ya
des candidats en tout cas qui ont leurs
propositions on va aller les voir
s'afficher un jean luc mélenchon 1
bloquer les prix tout simplement hidalgo
marine le pen baisser la tva à 5.5
yannick jadot vous dévoyez s'afficher un
chèque énergie je résume volontairement
valérie pécresse soyons libres forfait
kilométrique
jérôme rodriguez il ya des propositions
qui vous séduisent plus que d'autres
parmi ces candidats sans faire forcément
la pub de l'un d'entre eux mais en tout
cas sur cette question même de du
carburant et d'énergie mes mails tous
les gens vous venez me présenter son qui
aujourd'hui face à des mecs qui prennent
une navette pour aller dans l'espace
aujourd'hui ils ont dix fois plus de
puissance en pognon que ces gens là
aujourd'hui le problème de l'essence
c'est le côté vicieux de l'augmentation
des prix c'est parce que une journée on
va méthode qui centimes par 6 à lhassa
glisse de centimes par là un ou deux
centimes par ici et puis là on arrive à
1,062 moi je vais vous dire c'est du
concret j'ai perdu le droit de conduire
mais j'ai été maître de l'essence allait
longtemps que j'avais pas été mettre de
l'essence j'ai saigné du nez c'est
simple le concret c'est ça j'ai mis un
billet de 50 euros j'étais par le
complice j je veux 50 euros j'ai pas eu
30 litres en gasoil
50 euros je n'ai pas eu 30 litres c'est
ça qui percute dans la tête des français
c'est parce que tous les jours leur met
un centime de plus ils ne le sont pas
passés il ya un moment donné où il ya
rupture et c'est là où c'est trop tard
tous ces gens là les maquereaux et toute
autre personne aujourd'hui n'ont aucune
puissance face à des sociétés qui ont
plus on leur favoriser hollande déroule
le tapis rouge 1 parce que je ne pense
pas que le boulanger a le même ordre
d'imposition que peut avoir totale parce
que je vous garantis que la sécurité
sociale gré beaucoup mais vraiment
beaucoup mieux c'est que à défaut de les
contraindre on va contraindre les
français ne puissent se déplacer à
défaut de contraintes des sociétés qui
font des milliards et des milliards à ne
même pas remboursé l'ensemble de la
pollution qui créent des favories
l'ensemble des français c'est quand même
merveilleux ce pays on vit dans un pays
magique et c'est là où l'on compare le
concret parce qu on aura beau dire pour
sentir pourcentage pourcentage mais là
c'est du pognon jeu voulez-vous répondre
jérôme rodriguez pardon oui j 0 à la mi
temps qu'un que les grands groupes
pétroliers gagne de l'argent n'était pas
de problème sauf que sur un tarif des
carburants son ensemble 100 de la somme
il ya 65 à 70% qui part dans les caisses
de l'état donc les seuls qui sont
ça on le met la pression pierre pierre
cimon 60% de blé pour pouvoir par
exemple quand il ya une épidémie de
covile être superbement bien soigné à
l'hôpital je les lâche les 60% on a
lâché 60% depuis x années sur du gasoil
on se retrouve avec une épidémie la
gueule dans l'eau à ne pas pouvoir être
soigné dans de bonnes conditions pays la
france champion du monde de la santé il
ya un paradoxe il ya quelque chose qui
passe pas il ya quelque chose que les
français aujourd'hui ne se pose pas
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait déjà de cet
argent parce qu'on nous le prends ok on
peut comprendre les mécanismes on peut
les entendre mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
de ce pognon ou est-ce qui va que cet
argent pourquoi on n'a pas remboursé la
dette monde de de france avec tout cet
argent qu'on engrange avec nos taxes
avec nos taxes on appelle ça un impôt
solidaire aujourd'hui à des gens qui
donnent dans la renie
pas ses 65 sans pouvoir voyez ce que
c'est moi je voudrais juste qu'à un
moment donné qu'on essaie d'inverser le
problème je vais jouer pour donner juste
un dernier exemple on a en a violé parce
qu'on allait nous prendre 135 euros sur
le compteur linky
et on nous a donné comme argument de la
part d'edf que mais vous rendez compte
vous n'aurez plus de contrôleurs qui
passe chez vous mais moi je m'en fous
qu'il passe à la maison je paye 135
euros il a un salaire il peut nourrir sa
famille les joueurs et les gens ne
réfléchissent plus ça va m'enlever 135
euros bois ça va on est en france les
plus pauvres vont pas on va pas leur
enlever mais les plus riches mais tu va
financer un mec tu vas tu vas juste
enlever le boulot d'un mec parce que tu
es content qu'ils viennent pas chez toi
t'emmerder mais moi je suis content
qu'ils nourrissent ma famille sa famille
avec les 135 euros je voudrais juste que
les gens remettent les choses alors
bonne place quoi si à un moment donné on
paye on mérite de recevoir s'en faut à
défaut de recevoir et je suis désolé
j'ai un problème de prothèses en ce
moment mais moi les sens ça m'a fait
perdre un oeil quoi à l'excellence à
l'essai littéral du terme cette colère
qu'on entend effectivement ce réalisme
face à la pompe à essence à ce que c'est
quand même quelque chose qui peut jouer
des gros tours à emmanuel macron qui il
faut bien le dire pour l'instant ce
maintien quand même assez haut dans les
sondages à trois mois de la
présidentielle
mais c'est ça qui est incompréhensible
en fait le la place des modèles
vaincrons dans les sondages pose
question son bilan est difficilement
défendable j'en parlais sur le pouvoir
d'achat mais sur le reste enfin on n'a
rien vu la gestion sanitaire n'en
parlons pas c'est un autre débat mais à
part enfermer les français elle est
traitée de vouloir les emmerder on n'a
pas vu grand chose et derrière il est
évidemment là avec ses 7 ce prix de
l'essence qui est plus haut que lors du
mouvement des gilet jaune est toujours
l'idée a bien sûr de faire porter le pli
à la masse de français plutôt que au
pollueur payeur à ceux qui pourraient
payer le prix on voit bien qu'il ya un
problème or les français
n'ont plus la force d'aller dans la rue
on a l'impression ne serait ce que pour
défendre leurs libertés fondamentales
contre le pass and i ter déjà il ya très
peu de monde et puis voilà jérôme est
l'exemple de la violence d'état qui
s'est dès qu'ils s'est déversée sur les
manifestants gilet jaune je crois que
c'était une violence qui a été fait à
dessein pour déterrer pour faire peur
pour empêcher finalement qu'il ya
d'autres mouvements de masse populaire
contre un gouvernement qui gouverne
contre son pays tout simplement et je
crois que là aujourd'hui on a toutes les
clés pour que à nouveau y ait un
mouvement insurrectionnel quasiment que
ce soit là la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation la façon dont cet exécutif
nous traitent en piétinant les libertés
et qu'est ce qu'on voit creek de faible
mobilisation des syndicats qui de temps
en temps font une manifestation contre
un ministre qui était à ibiza la veille
de la rentrée dont visiblement ça ne
choque plus les profs et tout et que
tout est à l'envi c'est à dire que une
fatigue crois qu une résignation aussi
du fait de la violence de la force
finalement de bulldozer des mails bacon
d'exploser toutes les revendications
sociales de s'essuyer les pieds sur le
le finalement le paillasson de ses
revendications sociales et d'avancer
quoi qu'il en coûte le quoi qu'il en
coûte c'est quoi c'est à dire écoutez
rester tranquille on va vous financer
jusqu'à ce que vous fassiez faillite
quand on va débrancher le quoi qu'il en
coûte après les présidentielles sans
doute après que le maquereau se soient
déclarés candidats
là on aura les feuilles se sera d'entrée
très longtemps ce sera trop tard pour
pleurer et tout est comme ça c'est ce
que disait jérôme c'est à dire que on ne
se rend pas compte de ces petites hôte
de cette perte de liberté tout houda
doucement tout va crescendo mais
suffisamment lentement pour que personne
ne se rende compte de l'ampleur
finalement du danger et de la nécessité
d'une mobilisation nationale et et voilà
et pourtant quelques lanceurs d'alertés
sont là pour en parler mais
malheureusement on voit bien que
derrière il ya une tranquillité qui qui
moi me pose question merci en tout cas à
tous les trois pierres chasserait jérôme
rodriguez alexis poulain d'avoir été
avec nous pour pour débattre de cette
flambée des prix du carburant merci à
vous et c'est la fin de cette émission
rendez vous demain dès 20 heures pour
une nouvelle émission n'oubliez pas de
réagir décida de commenter de poser vos
questions sur le télégramme d'ayrté
france et l'actualité continue toute la
soirée
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit bout de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france fois et à la rivière l'aria tout
et c'est un peu dégueulasse
l'onic avachi clos pas ces unités il me
dit il n'ya même pas de pain en tournage
à vide mais une compote qui est bien sûr
est est-ce que vous avez une idée de qui
sont ces gens qui attaquent un lycée
pour sa part
ça risque d'en face
[Musique]
veut contenir tout le monde sur l'île
évidemment quand on est assis sur une
poudrière je leur jette n'aime pas la
pierre c'est bien d'accueillir mais je
cassais un mot leur donne de l'espoir et
puis à la fin on leur dit quoi non mais
t'as pas de papiers bah écoute
accroche-toi mais j'ai pas de conneries
pour une fois qu'on a la parole